my name is susie ritter and i've been an
owner and innkeeper of the hamilton
turner since 2013.
the inn is located in savannah georgia
the home was built
in 1873 by mr hamilton and it was a
private home for 100 years
and has been an end for the last 30
years mr hamilton had great parties here
and people would come from everywhere
the hamilton children like to get
involved and
roll the pool balls down the stairs so
they could make an excuse to get into
the parties
and people say now they hear the balls
rolling down the stairs
and kids laugh about that one morning i
came into the parlor
and there was a couple there and they
said the room
402 the room across the hall from them
five o'clock in the morning there were
two little kids banging on the door
telling them daddy let us in
there were no children in the house that
night people come here from all over the
country all over the world really
looking for some spirits
okay susie joins me now along with
medium anna raymonde
thank you so much for joining us today
anna
how do you connect with spirits how does
that work
um they come to me in every way i feel
them
i see them i hear them however they want
to come to me
they come to me i don't need to be in
the house to pick up on
energy in the house it just they just
find a way to get through to me that
said anna you have been
to the hamiltonix yeah um it's a really
big party house
um the the energy spirits that hang out
there like a good party there's always
music like i'm hearing
um piano playing um do you still have a
piano in there
no we don't have a piano yeah they want
they want the piano back
there's two people who play the piano
who want the piano back
and there's somebody pulling like a
feathery thing
who walks through the halls and she's
saying um
this is my house my house like almost
like i
set the pace for the fun do you know who
that is
i might take a guess that it was um that
it was
nancy hillis or mandy who was in
midnight in the garden of good and evil
well she's fine lots of fabulous parties
here yeah
from the ver from the get-go okay
there's also you know you talk about the
kids walking around
there's very young soldiers walking
around like they feel like they're
teenagers
and nurses the the home was a
nurse's station during world war one
they might have come during a period of
time that
was you know an upheaval you know a war
going on
but they still held on to who they were
their sense of humor the house has sense
of humor
susie does that make you feel more even
more safe than you already
did but like yeah i've always felt a
good
a good vibe coming from the house so
it's good to hear that
anna thinks that you know that they're
happy here
well i gotta tell you i probably was
there at that house at some point too
because i too like to party
so um i am really glad
because energy is everything and
if it's good and you can live around it
then well thank goodness so thank you
susie so much
you